en sus autos estas familias pasan de un
mundo a otro es el único puesto de
control entre los territorios ocupados y
los controlados por Ucrania
en este día La mayoría de los refugiados
vienen de gerson
cuando los rusos tomaron esta gran
ciudad del Sur en los primeros días de
la invasión los habitantes se
manifestaron rápidamente comienza la
represión hoy en día gerson es una de
las ciudades donde la resistencia es más
activa Román acaba de entrar a
territorio ucraniano está demacrado
agotado y milagroso ese soldado craneano
y combatiente de la resistencia fue
buscado activamente por las tropas rusas
en los alrededores de gerson
tigre entraron en el pueblo con
vehículos blindados si lo registraron
todo
buscando armas y Buscando a Los
partidarios sus francotiradores tomaron
posiciones dentro de la aldea y
comenzaron a despejar la zona en mi
pueblo por lo que entendí me
traicionaron
alguien dijo a los rusos
hay un tipo allí que dice que quiere
defender a su país
me buscaba a mí y buscaban a otro hombre
también era un patriota que hacía
cócteles Molotov Entonces llegaron unos
familiares me avisaron pude huir
pero el que estaba haciendo cócteles
Molotov fue golpeado con la culata de un
rifle en la cabeza
tenía daño cerebrales
romance esconde en el bosque sobrevive
durante cinco meses con la ayuda de los
campesinos el ejército ruso persigue sin
descanso a los miembros de la
resistencia en el frente sur este
ejército en la sombra está coordinado
con el ejército ucraniano
esta unidad compuesta por ucranianos
georgianos y voluntarios extranjeros
opera regularmente tras las líneas
enemigas
es muy peligroso atravesar las líneas
aquí porque hay muchas Minas trincheras
tienes que encontrar un pequeño espacio
donde puedas meterte
ponerte detrás y golpearlos lo más
difícil es salir salir de allí porque en
ese momento el enemigo entiende que en
algún lugar alguien está operando detrás
de tus líneas
[Música]
la información proporcionada por Los
partidarios dice que es esencial para
estas operaciones
en la ciudad de su pueblos que estamos
tratando de liberar por ejemplo hay
personas que envían información y viven
allí
bajo nuestros bombardeos también porque
estamos tratando de atacar objetivos
allí y no se van y quedan allí nos dan
información
información muy valiosa sobre el número
de tropas
dónde están Qué tipo de armas tienen
sus movimientos obtenemos mucha
información de ellos y espero que
después de la guerra estas personas sean
recompensadas y sean conocidas por la
población ucraniana
[Música]
desde el comienzo de la guerra o el ex
se dedicó a organizar la resistencia
fue alcalde de un grupo de pueblos en el
frente de gerson 5 están todavía
ocupados
teníamos personas en cada pueblo que
conocían las rutas y me informaban de
los movimientos que observaban
yo tenía conocimientos militares de guía
de ataque Así que recogía todas las
coordenadas y se las daba directamente a
la artillería
ese día visita es de clan forma parte de
la red de resistencia creada por oled
su pueblo fue ocupado pero ella nunca se
fue ahora se encuentra en primera línea
daroslas murió y su comandante quedó en
estado de conmoción el joven que estaba
allí También Era realmente una buena
persona estuve hablando con él esta
mañana y luego alguien me dijo que había
muerto
oled y svetlana aceptan hablar de su Red
porque creen que los rusos no volverán a
su pueblo
los chicos subían a lo alto de los
edificios con binoculos y observaban
veían los movimientos de las columnas
rusas informaban al ejército que luego
bombardeaba ahora el ejército tiene más
información ellos mismos pueden ver
mejor lo que sucede sin embargo hace muy
poco algunos chicos que aún estaban
activos me llamaron dijeron que habían
detectado una posición importante e
inmediatamente llamé a los militares
para darles esta información
Los partidarios también se centran en
eliminar a las personas que se han
Aliado con los rusos y a los que han
obtenido cargos en la administración
rusa gracias a ello
en junio por ejemplo
liquidaron al subdirector de la prisión
de novakakova
los traidores nunca deben sentirse
seguros siempre tienen que cuidar sus
espaldas y contar con que alguien vendrá
a buscarlos
[Música]
en los pueblos que administran dice que
solo ocho personas se han unido a los
rusos y agrega tenemos sus nombres y la
traición tiene un precio